do you like traveling do you enjoy
traveling I love traveling I mean I get
it I get a do it for work you should go
to Russia I'm gonna go to Russia with my
show yeah well I don't can't say when
but where we really want to do that I
mean that would be not know and and you
enjoy it you like you like traveling you
like love it I just people either do or
they don't there's like my wife's a
homebody I mean she likes to go
traveling some but she mostly just wants
to be home I just I love getting on a
plane and going someplace well I'm a
homebody who likes to travel so I travel
with like a lot of my home cuz to me
like a kitchen it well I'm also like
working and living and like other great
what are you I'm yeah but what do you
all have like a kitchen usually when I'm
working yeah and I'll bring a lot of my
kitchen with me I'll bring like
cast-iron skillets which are very heavy
and I'll bring my knife block and I'll
bring a lot of my might please tell me
you checked the knife block that that
goes through the yeah luggage
yes but I've also made the mistake of
not and I wasn't I didn't get in trouble
no one saw my butcher's knife what
what are you talking about they take out
I'll put this much shampoo yeah in a
bottle and it goes through and they rip
apart my suitcase and it's not enough to
lather one eyebrow and the next thing
you know I'm in a holding cell you go
through with the butcher's knife no that
was just yeah one bit I don't care if
it's one time wondering like how do you
do that by chance like well here's the
butcher's knife I'll put that in the
carry on and yeah like I think I thought
I was going to check the bag that I was
carrying on oh but I'm not positive but
I've also been the time I have been
stopped
I had a tool that's called a veggetti
like looks like an hourglass and as the
smallest blades on it but they but they
wanted they wanted to take what does
that do it's a spell like spiralize as
vegetables you bring that with you when
you go to another country yes why do you
need spiralized vegetables when you're
in ukraine because it's nice to you know
be in control of what you have to eat
and when you're working I don't know I
don't know I honestly don't know why I
started shouting at others if it'll see
because she brought that's a very nice
thing I mean joy gives you joy then do
it you must and do it yeah well I don't
know why I'm Yoda now
you